venait d'avoir 21 ans quand il a été
envoyé en Irak c'était en 2008
j'étais un jeune militaire idiot de 21
ans dit-il je voulais juste être déployé
je voulais être avec mes amis j'étais
chef d'équipe dans un Hercule c'est 130
et comme beaucoup d'anciens combattants
il ne comprend toujours pas pourquoi ils
étaient là quel était l'objectif
20 ans après les sentiments sont
partagés
et dit-il ça me dérange c'est très
difficile à comprendre
plus de 300 milliards serait mort durant
cette guerre plus de 4000 militaires
américains sans compter les blessés
vous m'avez envoyé en Irak mes amis sont
morts et on le sait ancien combattant à
George Bush en 2021
en mai 2022 lors d'un discours sur
l'invasion russe en Ukraine l'ancien
président fait ce lapsus
l'homme dit-il de déclencher une
invasion brutale en Irak invasion
qui n'en a pas fait sourire beaucoup
la guerre en Irak était une grande
erreur du robotford ambassadeur adjoint
en Irak en 2008 la plupart des
diplomates américains étaient
contre-t-il
[Musique]
le département d'État nous est dit que
la décision était déjà prise
utile et qu'il fallait arrêter
d'argumenter
pour beaucoup la guerre en Irak a
discrédité le gouvernement américain
depuis une certaine méfiance est
installée au sein de la population au
profit de mouvement comme make Markle
[Applaudissements]
a souvent utilisé la guerre en Irak
comme exemple dit-il pour justifier le
doute sur tout ce qui se dit à
Washington jusqu'à aujourd'hui
beaucoup de réticences à tout changement
de régime dit-il ou encore d'envoyer des
troupes au sol
au pays était brutal
j'évite compris qu'on allait jamais
avoir de parade à New York dit-il
à son retour étudiant droit aujourd'hui
il représente les anciens combattants
auprès du Congrès il fait le suivi et
c'est sûr qu'ils ont tous accès aux
soins de santé pour beaucoup d'entre eux
c'est un 20e anniversaire au goût amer
qu'ils aimeraient oublier il faisait au
Canada Washington